it is April 3rd 2023 and you're watching
the code report less than six months ago
Elon Musk paid 44 billion dollars for
Twitter and people have been dunking on
him ever since he fired half the company
gave blue check marks to The Peasants
and freed a bunch of people from Twitter
jail do not come
do not come I'm Gonna Come
in some ways it looks like Twitter is
collapsing it's now only worth 20
billion dollars many users have moved to
Mastodon the New York Times just lost
its blue check and even LeBron James
won't pay the five so did Elon buy
Twitter just to be the king and watch it
burn or is he actually playing a game of
5D chess against the mainstream news
media like the Fox News and CNN channels
that your grandparents watch he's
playing the long game to take their
advertisers by making Twitter the future
platform for all journalism and if he
plays his moves right I predict he will
become the richest man in the world even
richer than Elon Musk himself yesterday
he made a crazy move by open sourcing
the code to Twitter's recommendation
algorithm and it's some of the most
interesting code you'll ever see in
today's video we'll dissect the code and
explain why they want to make Twitter
like the Linux of social media companies
well kind of although it is real
production code at Twitter it's not 100
of the code so it's really only useful
for research and transparency the code
base is mostly written in Scala a jvm
language that's kind of like Java but
concise and just way better Twitter was
originally written with Ruby on Rails
but they moved away from it over a
decade ago everybody already kind of
knows how these algorithms work but it's
extremely interesting to see the real
deal implemented in code like this
method in the early bird tensorflow
based similarity engine.scalifile we
have a bunch of ranking parameters each
with a default value retweets provide a
20x boost while likes provide a 30X
boost and images and videos also provide
a small boost and not surprisingly you
also get a boost for being a pain
Twitter blue member like I said the New
York Times just lost its blue check mark
and now it's not verified so it could
just be a cap behind a screen on the
flip side a tweak can get a debuff if
the account has a lot of mutes blocks or
spam reports also spelling errors and
made up words will give you a debuff and
there's also a long list of topics that
won't be Amplified like anything that's
been flagged as misinformation
harassment putting bounties on people's
heads and many other no-nos the platform
also keeps close track of Elections and
there's actually Tools in place like
this government requested class that
allows president Camacho to keep you
safe from Bad content but taking a step
back we can break the total algorithm
into three parts first it finds a pool
of 1500 tweets that you might be
interested in use using a technique
called candidate sourcing it includes
accounts you follow but also out of
network sources by clustering similar
accounts together allowing it to find
relevant tweets from accounts that you
don't follow yet from there it ranks
that pool of tweets with a 48 million
parameter neural network and then
finally it filters out content by Static
rules like accounts that you've blocked
or muted there's also a second repo
called the algorithm ml that contains
the machine learning models used at
Twitter the project uses Pi torch and
they actually created their own in-house
embeddings that contain over a billion
nodes and hundreds of billions of edges
on the home feed it uses something
called the heavy ranker but some people
have criticized this for amplifying
misinformation the most controversial
block of code though was this one here
that keeps track of whether or not an
author is a democrat or republican or
whether it's Elon or a power user but
apparently this code is only used for
collecting metrics but has already been
removed one thing that's not found in
the source code though is its apparent
juicing of VIP accounts like AOC on the
left and Cat turd on the right which was
reported by platformer the code is
highly interesting and I recommend you
clone it and check it out yourself but
why would Elon do this why would he
release his trade secrets to the public
it kind of makes Twitter like the Linux
of social media the public can identify
things that are unfair in the algorithm
and address them in public it's mostly a
marketing move to build trust it no
longer feels like it's run by a
mysterious cabal that can Shadow ban and
de-boost content without some degree of
transparency and there's a huge
opportunity here because the trust in
mainstream media has fallen so low many
people already use Twitter to consume
the news and although Twitter is
currently losing money they've talked
about compensating content creators just
like YouTube and other platforms too
when that happens journalists could
potentially make a living on Twitter and
put their best content there Elon knows
Twitter blue is never going to make
Twitter any money but rather it's
designed to uplift independent creators
while embarrassing The Establishment the
blue checks are now irrelevant and by
open sourcing the code Twitter is laying
the groundwork to become the fair and
balanced most trusted name in news and
this may Force other social media
platforms to become more transparent
putting elon's balls in Zuckerberg's
Court this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one